new in theaters this week can and a few
family options to stream at home this is
your weekend ticket
[Music]
can comes out this weekend this sci-fi
action movie shows the importance of
family and why you shouldn't pick up
futuristic alien weapons you find in
abandoned buildings after Eli and
adopted twelve-year-old finds a super
powerful and potentially alien weapon he
must use it to protect his brother who
was recently released from jail
family drama much Jack Rayner zoe
kravitz Carrie [ __ ] Dennis Quaid and
James Franco all share the screen to
prove that no force is greater than
family this movie is for you if you like
sci-fi family action dramas brothers
doing what it takes to stick together as
a touching theme for you or you've ever
had an alien encounter and nobody
believes you if you don't want to go out
this weekend but want similar options
available on streaming we got you for a
futuristic family action drama check out
children of men with Claude Owen and
Julianne Moore if you want a movie about
brother sticking together check out step
brothers with Will Ferrell and john c
reilly both available on Fandango now
that's your weekend ticket what will you
see and check back next week for a
not-so-nice none
[Music]